hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm eating a
Koski eating Gutowski is back so Ian and
I are here today we're gonna check out
Dumb and Dumber and oscar-worthy drama
from the channel Nashville water cooler
Dumb and Dumber is one of my all-time
favorite comedies Dumb and Dumber to is
one of the biggest letdowns of my life
and a Dumb and Dumber will forget about
the other is my favorite of all time
yeah and I'm not gonna lie to ya I
didn't buy the Dumb and Dumber part two
I didn't mind it had some good luck
really I couldn't get through a Dumb and
Dumber parlando like that's some of the
best dumb comedy I've ever seen like
it's clever dumb money you know thank
you well over it's a car to get but
thanks i reaiiy say that at least twice
a day every day of my life did you pay
the gas bill
you sold the dead bird to a blind kid
yeah
hello how are you
names Christmas Lloyd Christmas I'm Mary
Swanson the most beautiful one alive
who'd asked in and out of my life you
just want to go to Aspen and find that
girl and you need me to drive you there
right yeah
you know I'm sick and tired of hair I'm
sick and tired of having to eat my way
through life just what I think you could
possibly be any you going through
something like
Wow that was really cool of me is there
anything after the credits no no no okay
whoa dude like the first half of that I
was like okay this is this is kind of
funny I mean when it was like serious
and stuff but when it became like indie
dramedy that's when it really is strong
that was so [ __ ] hilarious because
that was like kinda dramedy let's start
like tear up being like I like what they
did with it with the title text that
when they have the words like it's such
a stupid trailer thing to do to make
more impact and this guy did some really
good editing Ikey he was able to take
the right moments the right scenes and
use good music to really like the the
indeed dramedy stuff I thought was so
[ __ ] clever the way it all unfolded
the way it played out the shots and it
started really looking like an indie
drama d like it stopped looking like
Dumb and Dumber
and the shots like we look like a really
beautiful shots it's like you know T
don't you know I'm not looking at that
for damodar be like oh [ __ ] does a
really beautiful scene yeah like one
shot where he was like dressed in the
cowboy outfit I was like totally add it
to the effectiveness in the first half
of this video it was like yeah there's
he's taking that he's making it serious
but it's you get literally Dumb and
Dumber you know yeah the last half was
like this could be its own film yeah
that's fantastic
Mashable water cooler I don't know if
you're right I don't know if you're
something bigger than this channel and
on who you are but dude you're on the
path to success yeah because you put in
almost the same amount of work that I do
that's a massive yeah like this video
probably took you what like 20 minutes
to edit my videos take like an hour hour
and a half at it so that's that you just
bumping them up a little bit more than
they should just to kind of boost them a
little bit yeah yeah but this is like
simple stuff yeah doesn't think research
yeah
qebla job shops up you know yeah you've
done
good luck in your future listen guys if
you're new to the channel click this
button to subscribe to the real rejects
it'll be worth your time and then you'll
get labeled or reject who doesn't want
that even Gutowski has the eating
Gutowski channel and he has a show on
there called Satan's corner he's a
stand-up comedian performs live actually
you know like he's not one of those
stand-up comics or you're like oh
they're just starting out and they're
they're kind of funny but they're
probably gonna quit cuz we're really not
gonna get anywhere he has already gotten
places people did you referred Jim yeah
Jim Jeffries Rosie O'Donnell a lot of
you know through the years you know Bob
Saget Kevin Pollak and you know all that
Bobcat Goldthwait Yoga for Kevin Pollak
yeah and Bob Saget yeah all those dudes
Wow yeah two Meadows humming for Tim
Meadows yeah have you seen walk hard one
of my faves man that was like well you
don't want none of this [ __ ] dude we're
smoking reefer don't want none of this
feel bad when you wake up in the morning
we're just doing cocaine
it makes turn to all your bad problems
into good things